it's magical just to be here
i'm thinking about how many thousands of
stone
are on top of our heads man so let's not
think a lot about that
my name is kenny broad i'm the mission
specialist
kenny broad is a national geographic
explorer and chief exploration officer
of the virtual wonders team
i would describe kenny broad as a mad
scientist
as an expert caver he and memo may be
able to add crucial insight on how to
access the chamber below the pyramid
there's very few people that have the
privilege to go in here
i don't want to wait all right let's go
being involved in a new discovery
it gives you this feeling that you're
doing something larger than just
yourself
while there are no portals to the
underworld on the ground floor
they hike up to a sacred chamber which
holds some intriguing clues
and this is the
amazing room
here we are wow oh my gosh that's
incredible
yeah this is where the king used to
see it this is the jaguar throne
so the king used to sit here and i mean
it really sticks out
because it still has i assume the
original paint yes
from this royal throne kings watched
countless humans
sacrificed to the rain god chuck at this
nearby altar
could their remains lie in the veiled
crypt below
those are the original insets of is that
jade
this is jade to the maya
jade was a royal resource used to
communicate with the gods
but there's no local jade exactly yeah
they bring it
all the way from guatemala it was one of
very important
item only royalty had access to it
this context is not only a royal context
where the king used to
rest see it it's also a funerary one
there's a relationship with death here
in life resurrection resurrection the
cycle of the jet was a cycle
the ornate jaguar throne sits in front
of something even more grim
and ominous
this is an amazing wall for a number of
reasons and what we see here
is embedded bones they are long bone
long
human bones they are embedded on the
wall
this one there another one here
there my assumption as a
bioarchaeologist i believe these are
leg bones it looks like it would be a
femur exactly
or tbs if you ask me i would say yeah
that might represent
bones of ancestors right or people very
powerful what's your sense of what can
be behind this wall well
i do really believe that there is uh
something intentionally positive there
given the sacredness of the site the
importance of the place within chichen
itza
i believe it could be a burial back
there i mean
it makes logical sense it makes sense
yes yeah if somebody is buried here
it was for sure a very important person
a king
[Music]
you